la distance entre pour éviter un contact
les bikinis à droite première manoeuvre
une intersection 2011 il apparaît de
plus en main il y aura trois autres
maintenant pour ce qui est de la part
des quatre ans qu'on apprenait par
l'univers de la mode américaine
il montre un sac un terrain difficile et
touché l'année
dans la garonne après contact
ininterrompu aux côtés de 140 autres
délégués locaux pour accueillir la plus
importante
le problème de 400 ce que ça leur
protection
lorsque george shultz prendra place à
cette table aux côtés de 140 autres
délégués les locaux du quai d'orsay est
en trop exigu il a fallu louer le palais
de l'unesco pour accueillir la plus
importante conférence internationale
jamais organisée en france
le problème comment en assurer la
sécurité 700 policiers mobilisés dont
400 spécialistes de la protection
rapprochée du ministère de l'intérieur
qui a également prêté ces portiques de
contrôle
derniers réglages et c'est un roland
dumas rassurer qui a visité cet après
midi le palais de l'unesco le ministre a
tout vu y compris cette salle où seront
servis pendant cinq jours des centaines
de repas aux conférenciers cette
conférence fera en effet la première
conférence internationale de cette
ampleur depuis la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale
il s'agira de faire progresser l'idée
d'une convention universelle pour
interdire l'usagé mais aussi la
production de ses armes chimiques
rappel historique georges bortoli les
gaz asphyxiants furent la terreur des
combattants de la première guerre
mondiale de 1915 à 1918 ils firent cent
mille morts et plus d'un million de
blessés qui gardèrent les séquelles de
leurs brûlures jusqu'à la fin de leur
vie aussi dès 1925 un protocole signé à
genève et auquel ont adhéré centre est
et à un mille armes chimiques
hors la loi lacunes graves il interdit
l'usagé de l'armé chimique en temps de
guerre mais nullement sa fabrication ni
son stockage
de là vient que l'armée soviétique est
aujourd'hui le plus officiellement du
monde des unités spécialisées dans la
guerre chimique
au total soixante mille hommes disposant
d'un stock de trois à quatre cent mille
tonnes de gaz mortel les etats unis de
leur côté n'en détiennent si l'on nous
dira qu'une centaine de milliers de
tonnes mais d'un genre particulièrement
dangereux dans le cadre de la
coexistence des deux grands ils font ici
visiter cette usine de fabrication à une
délégation soviétique
seulement voilà outre les deux grandes
puissances qui déclarent leurs stocks
il ya les pays qui fabriquent des gaz
qui ne le disent pas mais qui parfois
s'en servent
d'où cette conférence de paris pour
interdire cette fois non plus seulement
usage des gaz mais leur fabrication leur
stockage tout tout tout avec beaucoup de
conditions pour en arriver là il faudra
notamment qu'on abandonne cette idée
selon laquelle après tout les pays
pauvres ont le droit de se doter de la
bombe chimique parce qu'ils n'ont pas
les moyens de se payer la bombe
nucléaire
c'est faux parce que la bombe nucléaire
ça ne s'utilise pas tandis que la gombe
chimiques
hélas ça s'utilise oui l'une des
dernière utilisation justement prouvé de
ses armes chimiques l'a été pendant la
guerre iran irak par exemple les
irakiens on utilise ont utilisé ces
armes contre les kurdes qui étaient sur
leur territoire dwan exode massif et 80
mille kurdes se sont réfugiés en iran
patricia cost et roger motte se sont
rendus il ya quelques jours dans un de
ces camps de réfugiés reportage
-20 degrés avant-hier soir dans les
montagnes du kurdistan
il fait nuit noire quand nous arrivons à
6 v un camp de réfugiés oubliés du monde
est arrivée mais au nom de dieu vous
devriez le savoir pourquoi me demander
on a eu le droit à tous les malheurs ils
nous ont arrosé avec des produits
ils nous ont aveuglé assourdi rendu fou
ils vont tuer massacrer ils ont
exterminé nos familles anéanties nos
maisons
voilà tout ce qui nous est arrivé la
retirer nous a bombardé puis l'aviation
ils ont tout utilisé quoi au mur les
images de leurs villages bombardés par
les irakiens
oga cyanure ou ypérite commun à la pch à
ce nuage jaune est la seule preuve films
et de leur poids des gaz par les
irakiens
c est fait des centaines de personnes
fauchées en quelques secondes le but
pousser les kurdes a quitté le
territoire irakien
une partie d'entre eux après un séjour
en turquie son passé en iran à 6 v nous
les avons retrouvés je ne vends rien pu
apporter avec tempo mais un verre de
rechange pour la lampe à pétrole
avant-hier de personnes quand sont allés
chercher durée sont hors jeu les sur la
route les problèmes quels problèmes
chacun afin que l'autre l'endroit où
nous sommes pas la peine de vous le
décrire des baraques sont porte sans
fenêtre planté en plein vent les mam
khomeiny nous est bien peu mais il a le
même ces difficultés m
nous attendons des journées entières des
camions de nourriture sans savoir qu les
jours le parquet leur île
et pollué qu'il n'y a pas des goûts
manière et le pire c'est le froid le
plastique qu'on a mis aux fenêtres ne
nous protège pas et ce sont les enfants
qui souffrent le plus je le dis
solennellement nous sommes dans
l'impossibilité d'assurer la survie d'un
âge enfants s'il n'y a pas une aide
extérieure
il y à bien un médecin au corps de civet
mais il ne se déplace pas il faut amener
le petit malade chez eux
même la de chaussettes dans les danses
le dr vient du bangladesh envoyé par son
gouvernement
on ne parle pas le cube ne voudra pas
nous dire combien il ya de décès par
jour
il se dit dans l'impossibilité de
diagnostiquer les cas d'intoxication par
gas décennies
la conclusion est terrible sous forme de
prière ne vous perdez pas de vue
agissez avec miséricorde pour que la
nation kurde ne disparaissent pas si
vous ne nous aidez pas tous ces films
seront qui l'unît les kurdes
un peuple presque oublié de king nous
aurons l'occasion en tout cas de revenir
sur cette conférence internationale sur
les armes chimiques dans tous nos
journaux pendant les 5 premiers jours le
reste de l'actualité maintenant à
commencer par la faire quand son grande
confrontation aujourd'hui face aux juges
quatre des cinq inculpés dans cette
affaire de captation de l'héritage de
suzanne deux camps sont le juge tente où
le savez d'établir la vérité d'une part
sur les causes de la mort de même de
canson et d'autre part d'enquêtés sur le
détournement de toute une série de
toiles de maîtres la confrontation avait
lieu à toulon michel perron paul lombard
en route vers la confrontation
les participants sont si nombreux qu'il
a fallu réquisitionner la bibliothèque
du palais de justice de toulon face à
face l'avocat et son juge
enfin réuni les quatre principaux
inculpés de la faire quand son mari
françoise pestel de bord ancienne
collaboratrice de m lombard inculpé de
complicité de faux et usage en écriture
privée robert boissonnet avocat
toulonnais et amis de joël pennel son
défenseur et jean louis pelletier
boissonnet est inculpé de vol
escroquerie faux en écriture et
non-assistance à personne en danger
celle enfin par qui tout tout arrive
aujourd'hui joël pennel qui changeant de
stratégie se met maintenant à part les
inculpés de séquestration vol
escroquerie et faux en écriture c'est
elle qui devait être la principale
bénéficiaire du détournement d'héritage
de suzanne de canson
ils ne sont que l'instruction
beaucoup de deux heures ne ressemble pas
aux déclarations très agressives qui ont
été faites contre maintenant barriol
deux jours
mais pour jacques vergès l'avocat de la
partie adverse
paul lombard sur la sellette semblait
plutôt mal à l'aise est-ce que ça
correspond à ce que vous imaginiez
ça correspond exactement à ce que
j'imagine
élément nouveau dans le dossier m
lombard aurait été mise en relation avec
madame pinel 20 83 ou des bus 84 dans un
premier temps j'aurai le panel se serait
adressé un amateur d'art jouant le rôle
d'intermédiaire après avoir vendu lui
même quelques-unes de ses oeuvres
il lui aurait conseillé vu l'importance
de la sphère de s'adresser à m lombard
pour les autres tableaux or jusqu'ici
l'avocat marseille avait toujours
affirmé n'avoir jamais rencontré joël
pennel avant début 85 date à laquelle
commence certes à s'engager les
négociations autour du gentilhomme
sévillan la bourse la première semaine
de janvier s'est achevée en apothéose en
deux semaines près de 10% de hausse à la
bourse de paris ce vendredi encore 1,3
pour cent de progression et c'est une
grosse affaire boursière qui secoue les
milieux politiques en ce moment là faire
pechiney au moment du rachat d'une
société américaine il y a eu récemment
des irrégularités des personnes qui
étaient au courant de la sphère aurait
profité de l'occasion pour empocher de
gros bénéfices c'est ce qu'on appelle à
la bourse un délit d'initié la cob la
commission des opérations de bourse
enquête ces investigations vont vers les
milieux politiques proches du pouvoir
véronique auger pour l'instant la
commission des opérations de bourse
écoute jean gandois le patron de
pechiney a bien sûr été déjà entendu il
pensait avoir mené son opération le plus
discrètement possible on découvre
qu'entre les avocats les banquiers les
ministres et leurs collaborateurs
plus de 70 personnes étaient dans le
secret et pourtant les premières fuites
sortie des dossiers de la cob désigne
tout des personnalités proches du
pouvoir
ainsi les enquêteurs ont d'abord reçu
max théret le fondateur de la fnac
vieux militant de gauche reconverti dans
le placement financier il déclare que
c'est seulement une aide confidentielles
sur pechiney qui lui a mis la puce à
l'oreille et qui l'a poussé à acheter
trente deux mille titres
trois jours avant l'annoncé de
l'opération autre personnalité entendu
roger patrice pelât
il aurait été mis dans la confidence par
max théret un ami de longue date
administrateur d'air france
monsieur plat est aussi un proche du
président de la république
la cob doit entendre prochainement à la
boue de lille le directeur de cabinet du
ministre des finances et pierre
bérégovoy de ces données hier soir moi
je souhaite que tous les noms sortent
il se trouve que de par mes fonctions je
les connais un peu mais je constate
c'est pas moi de naturellement de l'eem
faire connaître mais ceux qui sortent ne
sont pas les seuls concernés
le souhaite donc que l'enquêté aille
jusqu'à son terme et elle devrait nous
révéler quelques surprises simple délit
d'initié bien complot politique
toutes les hypothèses circulent à la
bourse c'est un jean pierre michaud
l'ancien juge de la sphère du carrefour
du développement du trouver la réponse
là en frais judiciaires avec les
audiences solennelles à la cour d'appel
à la cour de cassation françois
mitterrand était présent pour la rentrée
de la cour de cassation
il a profité de cette occasion pour
souhaiter de nouveau une refonte rapide
du code pénal comme il l'avait fait à
l'occasion de ses voeux de nouvel an
dominique verdeilhan valcourt le chef de
l'état ne s'était pas exprimé devant la
haute juridiction depuis 82 au centre de
cette cérémonie solennelle la réforme du
code pénal françois mitterrand a
réaffirmé devant les magistrats son
souhait de voir discuter au parlement le
projet du nouveau code pénal de l'ancien
garde des sceaux robert badinter
une réforme qui pour le chef de l'état
s'avère est incomplète sans la révision
des règles de procédure pénale mais
l'ensemble de ces réformes qui devront
se suivent sans hiatus excessif d'autres
à la france d'un instrument juridique
des d'une démocratie moderne
je vous avouerai sans fard que c'est
bien l'une de mes ambitions puisque le
temps mon a été donné par le peuple
français
réviser les statuts devant l'entrée de
la cour de cassation greffiers et autres
personnels de l'administration
judiciaire manifester leur
mécontentement
malgré la signature ce matin d'un
protocole d'accord entre syndicats et
chancellerie deuxième temps fort de
cette journée judiciaire la rentrée de
la cour d'appel de paris magistrat en
redit au garde des sceaux qu'ils avaient
pris bonne note de ces orientations pour
faire de la justice un service public
ainsi le procureur général pierre truche
a demandé aux juridictions de la région
parisienne de régler dans les six mois à
venir
les dossiers en souffrance depuis plus
de trois ans la préparation des
élections municipales à gauche on se
revoit mardi prochain à droite le rpr et
l'udf ont rendu public tout à l'heure la
liste de leurs chefs de file pour ces
élections méric au total pour 247
grandes villes il y aura 2 115
candidature unique c'est un petit peu
moins bien que ce qui avait été annoncé
un peu vite hier soir et puis il reste
quelques cartes très difficile lyon par
exemple ou un accord francisque collomb
michel noir paraît bien improbable
enfin à lille le barriste bruno durieux
a décidé de se maintenir face au
candidat rpr soutenu par l'udf roland
sicard les barriste n'aime pas se
laisser passer devant bruno durieux
moins que les autres ce député du nord
proche de raymond barre qui depuis des
années se prépare pour la conquête de la
mairie de lille n'a pas apprécié d'être
mis sur la touche les accords passés
hier entre l'udf et le rpr il est vrai
le sacrifice c'est le gaulliste alex
türk qui bénéficient de l'investiture
officielle
résultat aujourd'hui bruno durieux
contre attaque et accuserait presque ses
amis de l'udf de trahison cette décision
d abattage horn n'a aucune signification
ce sont des états majors qui comprennent
l'udf et le rpr et l'udf et un député à
lille le rpr n'a pas d'élu national sur
l'île
et voilà que l'udf ne soutient pas son
député on marche sur la tête
donc vous maintenez votre candidature à
la candidature
bruno durieux qui dans la sphère ne
s'embarque pas son biscuit pierre
méhaignerie pour le cds l'aurait assuré
de son soutien
alex türk de son côté joue la carte de
la légitimité et analyse à sa manière
l'éventualité du maintien de son
adversaire ça signifierait que bruno
durieux consomme à tenir jusqu'au bout
et prendrait donc le risque d'apparaître
comme l'allié objectif de pierre mauroy
car les créer la division chez nous
durieux contre eux turc une bagarre qui
risque effectivement de faire la sphère
de pierre moreau le maire de lille est
candidat pour le ps à sa propre
succession il pourrait bien être
l'arbitré de la primaire à droite en
italie une affaire de bien mauvais goût
on avait cru au retour des brigades
rouges lit à deux jours nous vous
parlions d'un attentat contre le
directeur adjoint de la prison de rome
en fait la sphère avait été monté de
toutes pièces par le directeur adjoint
lui-même parce qu'il ne se voyait pas
vieillir entre les murs de la prison
agnès poirier le directeur adjoint de la
prison de rome veut être muté il ne
supporte plus la vie en prison il décide
de se faire enlever par les brigades
rouges
j'ai entendu des cris des coups de feu
raconte t-il aux policiers aux
journalistes et puis plus rien je me
suis évanoui de douleur il balle dans la
jambe
s'ils sont guère de l'histoire en
faisant usage de son arme qui aurait
misé en fuite les agresseurs
ces derniers précisent ils se sont
réclamés des nouvelles brigades rouges
mais les policiers se montrent
sceptiques la tentative d'enlèvement ne
semble pas le fait de professionnels et
les brigades rouges les vrais nie toute
participation à cet attentat
les policiers découvrent enfin dans sa
voiture de faux tracts des nouvelles
brigades rouges
et c'est sur son lit d'hôpital qu'il est
inculpé de simulation de délits et
d'idiot deluca va devoir reprendre goût
à la vie carcérale plus vite et
peut-être plus longtemps que prévu
l'union soviétique respectera la date du
15 février pour se retirer d'afghanistan
c'est ce qu'affirme la résistance
afghane
les moudjahidine discute en effet en ce
moment avec une délégation soviétique
en échange les moudjahidine se sont
engagés à ne plus attaquer l'armée rouge
si celle ci se retire bien le 15 février
d'autres faits marquants de l'actualité
de ce vendredi pascal vigné frison sous
haute surveillance à new delhi police et
remet sur le pied de guerre les
autorités indiennes redoutent une
explosion de violence après la pendaison
ce matin d26 assassin d'in dire à gandhi
aidé à des centaines de kilomètres de là
amritsar elle est restée ville morte
la capitale religieuse des ciq a pris le
deuil aujourd'hui en hommage à ce
qu'elle appelle déjà ses martyrs
enquête sur l'explosion du boeing de la
panam le leader de l'ol paie aujourd'hui
en visite en jordanie affirme détenir
des renseignements importants et vouloir
coopérer aussi bien avec les états unis
qu'avec les gouvernements européens pour
découvrir les auteurs de l'attentât
le 21 décembre dernier 270 personnes
avaient trouvé la mort à lockerbie en
écosse deux jours que ça dure des
dizaines et des dizaines de milliers de
litres d'essence qui se déverse à
quelques centaines de mètres d'un
influent du rhône cela se passe près de
valaury dans la drôme un bulldozer qui
éventre par accident a eu lieu duc et la
pollution menace ce soir la brèche a
enfin pu être colmatée mais le principal
risque vient maintenant des
infiltrations d'essence dans le sol
madonna et sean penn ont chances de
disque la chanteuse et l'acteur ne
vivait plus ensemble ils ont
officiellement décidé de divorcer après
trois ans et demi d'une union orageuse
même tapageuse le mari ombrageux se
faisant notamment une spécialité de
boxer les paparazzi le couple reconnaît
donc son échec
mais qu'on se rassure le divorce sera à
l'amiable tout n'est peut-être pas perdu
ou en skis reprise de la coupe du monde
avec une descente hommes à laax en
suisse est aussi un slalom géant dames
en autriche à schwarzenberg
alors victoire en suisse la revenant
autrichien leonard stock et en autriche
victoire d'une suissesse abonnés à la
victoire c'est vrai ni schneider jean ma
mère
souriante et acclamé la star des stars
du moment vernis schnyder est imbattable
elle a remporté sa septième victoire
consécutive en coupe du monde
rennes là l'homme géant et du slalom
spécial la double championne olympique
pourrait bien remporter sa huitième
victoire dès samedi dans le deuxième
album géant de chardonne baird
l'envol du revenant l'autrichien leonard
stock huit ans après son titre olympique
de lake placid il reprend contact avec
la victoire et remporte la deuxième
descente de sa carrière
il confirme son retour au premier plan
et celui de l'autrichien qui prennent
les trois premières places
leurs compatriotes ni verseur lui ne
remontera pas de sitôt sur des skis il
ne se relèvera pas seul de cette
terrible chute
victime d'une fracture du bassin et d'un
arrachement des ligaments du genou une
nouvelle mobilisation pour aider
l'arménie la croix-rouge et le
croissant-rouge lancé un appel pour
collecter de nouveaux fonds notamment
pour la construction d'un centre pour
les accidentés
autre mobilisation en france cette fois
les comédiens et chanteurs réunis par
charles aznavour il s'agit de préparer
un disque et un clip qui sera d'ailleurs
tourné par henri verneuil
voilà qui espère on donnera un petit peu
de baume au coeur aux arméniens qui
aujourd'hui fêter noël dans la tradition
arménienne
en tout cas vous allez le voir les
artistes rassemblés par aznavour était
nombreux et enthousiaste
oh
av
ouais
à
et
ils ont mis
non
à
ma
au tableau d'honneur cette semaine c'est
que ça génère encore prévert de plus en
plus jeunes même fait tintin et oui il
ya 60 ans par effet le premier album de
tintin c'était un tintin au pays des
soviets fait paru dans le journal le
petit vingtième est ce soir notre invité
fait papin et oui bonsoir tintin alerte
1 c'est vrai vous avez 60 ans pour
beaucoup c'est l'âge de la retraite mais
vous n'avez pas vraiment écouté 60 ans
pour quelqu'un qui s'adresse aux 7 à 77
ans encore le bel âge c'est pas moi qui
ai vieillissent et le monde qui change
un exemple entre le pays des soviets de
1929 et gorbatchev ya changement le
congo que j'ai connu c'est aujourd'hui
la ire le proche-orient du crabe aux
pinces d'or c'était des colonies le
shanghai du lotus bleu une concession
britannique alors vous savez 60 ans
alors c'est vrai tintin beaucoup ils ont
reproché d'avoir une vision du monde
colonialiste conservatrice et puis
misogyne aussi et aujourd'hui je peux
vous révéler que je n'ai pas toujours
été d'accord avec mon père rg là dessus
c'était l'époque qui était comme ça
qu'est ce que vous voulez quant aux
femmes c'est parce qu'ils trouvaient lui
à la castafiore mais il ya deux mille
sabords comme dirait haddock
s'il avait dessiné betty boop par
exemple sera peut-être été autre chose
une histoire d'amour par exemple betty
boop pourquoi pas en tout cas tintin on
peut dire que dans les albums que vous
avez fait avec hergé vous avez été très
visionnaire je vous propose de regarder
avec nous ce sujet préparé par rémy
roche
attention pour les décomptes finals dix
neuf huit sept six cinq quatre trois
deux un feu
1950 d'hergé fait décoller de la base de
ce brunch en syldavie la fusée conçue
par le professeur tournesol vols habités
objectif lune
et sharon lift off
voyage handisport au presque aller ni
sage parfait 7 à tintin que revient
l'honneur de fouler en premier le sol
lunaire
armstrong pour la nasa devra lui qu'en
juillet 69
on ne peut pas dire qu'il a qu'il a
inventé la lune au même titre que jules
verne l'avez inventé parce qu'il s'était
basé déjà sur la documentation de son
temps il s'est basé sur ce qu'on était
en train de faire sur ce qu'on était en
train de dire
mais enfin beaucoup de scientifiques n'y
croyait pas à la réalité de la lune
hergé lui y croyait et atteint donc qui
a été avant armstrong autres travaux
publiés dans les bijoux de la castafiore
au début des années 60 les premiers
balbutiements de la télé couleur noire
réjouit son invention de la piraterie
aérienne avant 68 à bord du vol 714 pour
sydney enfin je n'attends pas le paris
dakar pour faire airs et ses héros dans
le désert avec ses pièges
et en tout cas tintin votre métier
c'était d'être reporter seulement dit
moi comme reporter on vous a jamais vu
écrire beaucoup d'articles comme un mini
présente et de journaux à la télévision
par exemple
vous connaissez beaucoup de reporter qui
ont été sur la lune qui connaissent le
secret de la licorne ou qui ont été chez
les incas j'ai même fait des scoops
comme vous dites la seule interview du
getty disons que mes articles ce sont
les albums d'hergé et que je suis un
journaliste engagé engagés dans des
aventures et aujourd'hui j'aimerais bien
chez les martiens par exemple avant les
autres à ce propos qu elles sont
quel a été votre aventure préféré 21
dirait sans doute le lotus bleu et est
atteint au tibet à cause de chang savez
c'était un sculpteur chinois qui a bien
connu rg qui est toujours vivant ce que
l'amitié c'est le b à ba de la bd mais
dites moi vous n'auriez pas vu milou à
propos voilà merci et un peu merci
beaucoup
on peut souhaiter en tout cas tintin et
milou un bon séjour à moulinsart avec le
délicieux capitaine haddock
et puis je crois que l'on peut remercier
aussi ceux qui ont réalisé cette
étonnante séquence alors je dis leur nom
josé alex l'yonne badea nu et durant
puis enfin laissez moi vous présenter la
nouvelle formule du journal de tintin
c'est tintin reporter ça s'appelle comme
ça maintenant ça paraît tous les
vendredis alors une fois encore bons
amis verts certain temps voilà pour
terminer les pronostics du tiers fait de
pierrette brès demain c'est à vincennes
les pronostics de pierrette 18 8 6 12 9
17 3 et 10 et j'ajoute que vous pouvez
retrouver dorénavant pire est le samedi
vers 18 heures
après samedi passion pour une émission
où elle présente ses pronostics
de même les mercredis et vendredis
veille des tirs c'est donc vous pourrez
la voir chaque fois présenté ses
pronostics à 11h55 cross-média fin du
journal tout de suite la météo avec
laurent cabrol 23h après postroff ce
sera henri sannier pour la dernière
édition
et puis pour les journaux du week-end
vous retrouverez comme d'habitude daniel
bilalian betty dureau et philippe
gayssot à lundi